hey everyone this is stephanie wong
cloud developer advocate we are back
with our own google fellow eric brewer
last time we talked about his last 10
years of building infrastructure at
google and kubernetes influence in the
space he mentioned how he is now
focusing on creating processes for more
secure software supply chains so eric
how are you doing today fantastic it's
good to see you again good to see you
too
all right so let's dive right into it
last time we were talking about supply
chains for software now you were talking
a little bit about the risk space and
companies tied to it so how is the
supply chain risk assessment happening
today
why is the risk so large well i think
there's a lot we need to do here as an
industry and it's it's beyond the power
of just google in fact it's it's really
quite a challenge for the whole planet
but i would say the first thing we need
to decide is you know which projects we
want to actually bet on because in some
sense any project you're betting on for
security you'd like to make sure that
there are people that care about that
project and are paying attention to it
and will fix security vulnerabilities as
they arise
because in practice 99 of our
vulnerabilities literally 99 are not in
the code that you write for your
application they're in this very deep
tree of dependencies some of which you
may know about some which you may not
know about and so
first thing is what are those
dependencies which ones are well
maintained which ones are not we're
starting to present that kind of
information
but take it up a level it's actually
going to be important for all industries
industries to try to understand what
pieces of software do we want to bet on
and why and what do we do about the ones
that are not quite up to par yet yeah
and whether some companies know it or
whether they have come to an acceptance
of it kubernetes has become the de facto
way to build and deploy
many many applications today
or at least that's the north star for
many organizations and now it has
several hundred software library
dependencies right so what are we at
google cloud doing to help reduce those
vulnerabilities
well there's tons as a course cncf we
started
as a home for kubernetes
and it's part of the linux foundation
which we also are big fans of and
funders of i personally helped create
open ssf open source security foundation
that in my mind started in 2019 although
i think it actually launched early 2020
but that foundation is in fact
explicitly targeted open source security
and the supply chain it was created for
that purpose and fortunately it was
created before the stuff really became
so visibly bad but i could see it coming
and that's why we needed to kind of
start early
the other thing i would say is that you
know google has a long history of
contributing to open source and in our
recent
response to the white house we've
committed another 100 million to open
source in the coming years
and
it's important to set that precedent
because the
the repairs we need there's a lot of
mundane work to do to make open source
as secure as we need it to be and it's
not fair to say oh
you know volunteers and others please
work harder
that's that's not going to be the
sustainable path and in fact i'm arguing
for federal funding as well
for open source security i kind of feel
like we need to get to a
sustainable model where
the kind of ongoing work of security
which is you know not easy stuff is
actually financially supported not just
for this year when it's a crisis but for
the future
by the way i think the same way as you
think about other public infrastructure
we passed a trillion dollars to spend on
roads and other things in the u.s uh you
know
open source is a public infrastructure
also and like all public infrastructures
it needs maintenance and support and so
we have to figure out how that's going
to work it's not at all an easy thing
but i do think data is part of the path
of the future yep and it's really hard
to predict that and so i think having
the secure processes in place from build
to deploy is
really key especially as we've seen the
detrimental work of adversaries coming
to light
now can you talk a little bit about our
contributions and the work that we've
done in the open source space
what are some of the organizations and
the projects that we've worked on
i'm a big fan as you know of kind of
raising the level of traction over time
and that gives developers more leverage
it allows us to do more automatically on
both the security side and the
management side
and autopilot is a great example of that
it's really we will manage the nodes for
you and your cluster and you don't have
to
and that is a security improvement but
it's also frankly just a toil
improvement why do the toilet of
managing those nodes if you don't need
to all right that's probably not why
you're doing your
your kubernetes job you probably have
something you'd like to do like a a
business app or a website or
data analysis
focus on those things and we can manage
the nodes and that general direction
is the way it's going to go we can
manage more things over time but they'll
be the things that you don't want to
manage yourself because it's a hassle
exactly and i do want to dive a little
bit more into google kubernetes engine
and what we've been doing over the last
couple of years uh i know that we just
had gke's sixth birthday actually
so why don't we go ahead and save that
for the next episode thank you so much
once again eric and to everyone else
watching stick around because we are
gonna have more soon
[Music]